ولكن إذا نظرت إلى تلك الخريطة ، فلنضعها
مرة أخرى ، فهي توضح كيف أن البلد
بأكمله باللون الأحمر
وهذه هي الحالات التي نعرف
عنها فقط منذ أن قلت أن الكثير من
الناس لا يختبرون ما يجري مع
هذا الطبيب البديل الجديد
حسنًا ، إنها معدية مثل
الحصبة ولديها أكبر تهرب مناعي من
أي متغير
رأيناه وأنت تعلم بينما
يزعم الكثير من الناس النصر في
فبراير وألغيت البلديات
تفويضاتها الجماعية للتخفيف ، استمر الفيروس في
التحور
وتحور و  لقد تحور ، والآن
يوجد
ba5 ولقاحاتنا ليست جيدة حقًا في
منعك من الإصابة
لحسن الحظ ولحسن الحظ ، لا يزالون
جيدًا في منعك من
الإصابة بالمرض الشديد أو الحاجة إلى
دخول المستشفى أو حتى الموت ، لذا فإن
لقاحاتنا حقًا  تم الاحتفاظ بها من أجل ذلك
لكنهم لم يتحملوا جيدًا الآن
للعدوى
، وإذا لم تكن قد تطمع في
الماضي
، فأنت تذهب إلى مكان مزدحم الآن
، فمن المحتمل أن تخرج مع uh ba5 wo
إذا كانوا يعملون الآن على هذه
الخطة للسماح باستخدام التعزيزات المرغوبة الثانية
للبالغين ، فأنت تعلم
تلك اللقطة الرابعة ، ولكن بالنظر إلى مدى
مراوغة هذا البديل للقاح
والعدوى السابقة ، إلى أي مدى تعتقد
أنه
ستساعد هذه اللقطة الرابعة على ذلك
حسنًا ، ما أعتقد أنه سيفعله
وأعتقد أن ما نعلم أنه
سيفعله هو المساعدة في منع الإصابة بأمراض خطيرة ، ما
نحاول فعله حقًا هو منع دخول
الأشخاص إلى المستشفى ،
وقد
تضاعف عدد حالات الاستشفاء خلال الشهر الماضي بشكل أساسي خلال
الشهر الماضي  وعلى مدار
الأسبوعين الماضيين ، رأينا أن الوفيات بدأت في
الارتفاع أيضًا ، وعلى الرغم من أننا لسنا
قريبين من المكان الذي كنا نعرفه في
ديسمبر أو يناير ، لا يزال هناك حوالي 300
شخص يموتون كل يوم حوالي
2000 شخص في الأسبوع
وإضافة القدرة إلى نوع من
تعزيز الأجسام المضادة لدى الأشخاص الذين تقل أعمارهم
عن 50 عامًا والذين لم يحصلوا بعد على جرعة معززة ثانية ،
يجب أن يساعد تلك المجموعة في
منع أه المرض الخطير والدخول إلى
المستشفى أو الموت لذلك أنا  أعتقد أنها
فكرة جيدة
في الخريف سنرى على الأرجح نسخة جديدة أه
من اللقاح الذي
يتضمن حماية أه ضد ba5 لكن
هذا لن يكون هنا حتى الخريف على
الأرجح